okay now great question do I have the
right plant Thank You senator every
single time guess what the great thing
about this is can you see all the
questions we've done them the same way
that the same series of steps now what
matters you just do is when they see
there's a process we got over and over
and over again we can say look we can
boil this down to instead of a series of
steps I can boil it down into a formula
and that's what we're gonna do in this
last part I'm gonna boil it down to a
formula just a little bit okay all right
so here we go
now we're going to think about this code
situation rather than like you know
actual numbers like negative 4 and
negative 1 what if you have any two
points any two points okay so I've got
my a by B I don't know what their
coordinates are yet but I'm going to
give them some names okay so this first
one down the bottom I'm gonna call it x1
y1 okay cuz this is the x-coordinate and
this is the y-coordinate the reason why
I attached a number is because well I've
got another X&Y coordinate up here and I
don't want to mix them up right so these
are the first pair of coordinates yeah
that's right so this is another x value
up here I'll call that X 2 and another Y
value I'll call that Y 2 okay okay so
I've got it I've got an X in the y
coordinate here and an X in a
y-coordinate here okay now let's do the
rise let's do the right okay now how did
I get this vertical distance in here all
right look back at the first example I
did sikhs take away one right look at
this next example I did three take away
negative one yeah good so I'm taking
away one one y-coordinate from the other
I'm gonna go y2 minus y1 okay yeah which
is gonna give me this length okay now
I'm just gonna leave it like that cuz I
don't know what the numbers are yet
all right so I could simplify this just
yet
no not yet right
you'll see why get it okay now in the
same way in the same way for the run for
this horizontal distance instead of the
Y coordinates I'm going to subtract the
X the x coordinates good
it'll be x2 minus x1 okay now this point
before we we would get what these
numbers are we'd say although this is 4
and although this is 9 and then I put
them into Pythagoras theorem okay
now I don't know what the numbers are
but I can still do Pythagoras with it
watch where am I gonna have enough space
I'll fit it over here I'll say a B
squared is equal to right and then I
need to square one and square the other
can you see that so all right y2 minus
y1 and I square the whole lot so just
look back at how we did this before why
it's 2 minus 1 in the previous case he
gave us 4 right so then you said what's
4 squared so down here you can see well
this might be 4 and then you square okay
so there's this one and then I add on I
do the same thing for the X's right x2
minus x1 we worked out what that was was
a number and then you square it so this
line here I know it looks long and
awkward but all that is is Pythagoras
okay now this is the last time I'm gonna
round up here
I thank your sister okay all right now
one more step one last step I actually
want the distance not the square of the
distance okay so what did we do in the
previous cases have a look bit yeah
right so I'm gonna take the square root
of this whole right hand side I know
it's very long right but that's okay
well we had actual numbers to put in
here it'll be fine
and we took the square root so I'll say
look we only want the positive square
root
right okay now see that see that line
right there that is the distance formula
it's it's so important that's right one
more time in big letters in and I've
even made a box for you you do it's a
square root of y2 minus y1 or squared
plus X 2 minus X 1 all squared okay now
I'll admit this does look really long
and difficult to remember but look at
where it came through okay it came from
Pythagoras and we're good at Pythagoras
we've been doing Pythagoras for years
okay you can see it's something squared
plus something else squared that's from
Pythagoras right so that's how you use
this formula okay